you were just saying that you follow the
situation in sri lanka very closely
yeah there's a lot of people who've uh
refugees from sri lanka particularly
tamil community
and i represent all of tamil uh british
tamils
and they have always been pretty angry
by the government there the rajapaksa
family who got the president and the
prime minister
and uh frankly have run the whole
economy in a very corrupt way
and have mismanaged the economy and now
it's affecting the lives of of everybody
in sri lanka
so
i hope our government will be sending
the strongest signals to tell the
rajapakse government it's time for them
to go
what um
intel did you get from the queen's
speech yesterday when it comes to our
government's view on our own cost of
living crisis
not a lot i mean i was hugely
disappointed as i was expecting
that after
the people had said during the low
collection results they were not happy
the government would take some action
but there was nothing for the cost of
living and there are millions of facts
what do you want them to do
there's no money
there is we need a vat tax cut that's
what little democrats have argued for
with 600 pounds and you can pay for that
by asking the oil and gas companies to
to pay winful tax they're making huge
profits and that's the flip side of this
higher uh heating bills and the higher
prices of the the petrol pumps the
government minister on the program
earlier in the week said they're paying
enough tax for now
well um i disagree with him um i want a
fair tax i'm on a fair society i want to
help people
and when a company needs these oil and
gas companies are making profits they
never expect to make these a huge super
profit
it's only fair to ask them to pay the
money to help people who are having to
pay those bills it was really
interesting one of the chief executives
of these companies said the other day
that um their investment plans would not
be affected at all by windfall tax which
is the government's previous argument
they're using against it and so the
government have got nowhere to hide now
they should ask these oil and gas
companies to pay more money and then we
have that money for the tax cut that
millions of families and pensioners need
how worried are you about the northern
ireland protocol being ripped up we had
um mr gove on the program just a few
moments ago and he was basic he said it
was never set in stone it was something
that was always fluid and and was meant
to be negotiated along the way
well i have to say i disagree with uh mr
gove it was an international treaty
international treaties aren't settings
are on fluid and flexible they're
they're clearly treated what worries me
about this is the government seem to be
prepared to contemplate a trade war with
our european
neighbours a trade war
a time of a cost of living emergency
would be an absolute disaster people
need to be aware that if the government
go down that route
the inflation we've seen so far will get
even worse
the supplies of things in the shops
would get even worse and you know the
government needs to be helping people
people are really struggling and for
michael gove and boris johnson and the
rest of them to think that a a trade war
is the right way to deal with a cost
living crisis an economic crisis i don't
know what planet they're living on well
interestingly i did put that to him and
he said that that would just not happen
there's not going to be a trade war well
i i i sincerely hope there isn't but if
they're thinking of
ditching the the protocol which was the
international treaty let's remember that
boris johnson signed it was his idea
if they now turn their back on that um
the danger is there would be a trade war
i mean let's be realistic about this and
and i really worry about that i worry
about that for the people of northern
ireland for the business of northern
ireland and i worry about it for the for
people across united kingdom people are
already
hurting enough uh they're really
suffering they're worried about the
increase in heating and energy bills
that's going to come this autumn they're
worried about the higher taxes they're
paying for the conservatives now to say
well it's okay we'll be a trade war i'm
sorry that's just not acceptable
you talk about energy uh costs uh i also
put it to mr gove that before brexit he
did say that that would be cut on energy
bills um that hasn't happened
he's now said that that is because it
would be a five percent cut for
everybody and dukes and princes don't
need that cut
well um uh
the problem with mr gove and the
conservatives is they keep breaking
their promises
this is not the only promise they've
broken they promised not to
raise taxes and they've risen they've
put up taxes they promised not
pensioners that they would keep the
triple lock on pensions they've broken
that promise this is a government that
breaks promises left right and center
and it's hurting people out there but do
you think a cut on the
vat on energy bills is the right way
forward i think a broader cut in vat is
the right way forward i wouldn't just
limit to energy bills food prices are
going up petrol prices are going up the
way to really help people in a very big
and bold way is what liberal democrats
are arguing for which is a two and a
half percent cut in vat down to 17.5
uh that would give the average family
600 pounds
a year so i think that's the sort of
bold measure that's needed you can only
be enough there is it for energy bills
600 quid well it would go some way i
mean we have a another set of policies
linked to that which would help the most
vulnerable because 600 pounds would be
for everybody uh for the average family
but there are pensioners uh disabled
people people on very low incomes who
will need some extra help so we've
argued that what's called a warm home
discount which takes money directly off
people's energy bills that that should
be doubled and the number of people who
could get that would be should be
increased so that's real help to people
who are struggling where are you on
secure stammer and um beer gate
well um at the weekend uh i was
suggesting that uh he would have to
consider a position if he got a fixed
penalty notice he would he would have to
um and then
earlier this week he actually said
that's what he positioned he would take
that if he got a fixed penalty notice
from the durham police he would resign
um and i was actually
quite pleased to see him say that
because i think that shows
integrity and willingness to to accept
the consequences and i just wish that
the prime minister showed some integrity
yeah but in march he did say i think it
was in march and the leader of the
opposition said because the prime
minister was being investigated by the
police he should resign and now he's
being investigated by the police but
he's not resigning
well uh listen he's got to make his own
decision right right right well he i
i've said that i think it's at least
good that he said he's prepared to
resign if he gets a fixed penalty notice
uh i just know the prime minister's had
a fixed penalty notice he's not resigned
i also note there's a possibility that
the prime minister might get even more
fixed penalty notices so you know the
prime minister's in charge of our
country he's supposed to be helping
people uh who are struggling he's not
doing that and my worry is he's he's not
giving leadership he's now become a very
weak leader because he's dogged by this
these crisis we're almost out of time
but my question is um
should the leader of the opposition who
is now uh part of a criminal
investigation resigned given that that's
what he said the prime minister should
do well um uh i i haven't said that i've
been very clear on my position uh
throughout this he
he he's got to decide he's his own uh
position i actually called on the prime
minister to resign not when there's a
police investigation i called for him to
resign before that and i explained why
he had said he he he he lied to
parliament about parties and it turned
out with allegra stratton's uh comments
that there were parties so my uh problem
with the prime minister is not just that
he broke the law but he's dishonest okay
it's good to see you sired thank you for
joining us on the programme this morning
thank you